el verano europeo se acerca a su fin y
el continente se prepara para un duro
invierno con los precios de la
electricidad disparados la inquietud de
los líderes del bloque comunitario se ha
hecho sentir olaf scholz canciller
alemán pidió una solución urgente a la
crisis energética y recordó que el
bloque comunitario trabaja bajo presión
república checa- que asume la
presidencia temporal de la unión europea
anunció una reunión urgente
si usted hemos convocado una reunión de
los ministros relevantes y el consejo
europeo para el 9 de septiembre y
esperamos que para esa fecha hayamos
llegado a una buena solución
la comisión europea ya ha pedido a los
estados miembros que reduzcan su consumo
de energía en un 15% pero ha reconocido
este lunes que no es suficiente
a los precios de la electricidad
disparados dejan en evidencia por varias
razones las limitaciones de nuestro
mercado de la electricidad actual
and that's why we es por eso que en la
comisión estamos trabajando en una
intervención de emergencia y una reforma
estructural del mercado eléctrico market
sobre la mesa está la regulación de los
precios de la electricidad una opción
que ayudaría a evitar que el peso de la
crisis recaiga desproporcionadamente en
los bolsillos de la población europea y
especialmente de la población más
empobrecida
la última semana el precio del gas en
europa rompió récords con un valor de
343 euros por megavatio/hora 30 veces
más que hace dos años el fin de la
crisis no se divisa cerca las relaciones
entre la unión europea y rusia- no
mejorarán mientras la guerra en ucrania
dure y reducir la dependencia del gas de
moscú tomará tiempo